we've heard the sound of coalition jets
overhead
all morning what we are witnessing now
may very well be the final push
against the islamic state throughout the
morning we've heard the crack of
small arms fire there's been plenty of
artillery
pounding the islamic state positions and
just make out the smoke on the horizon
they're about a kilometer kilometer and
a half away
the lorries in the foreground that is
the start of the
what was the tented encampment but the
syrian democratic forces
are now pushing in and the fact that the
fighting is going on throughout the day
suggests that they are not going to stop
until that area
is cleaned of daesh now
a couple of nights ago the fighting
resumed again after a cessation
of hostilities that was to let women and
children come out
nobody is coming out at the moment so
the impression you are getting from the
sdf is that the people
still inside are islamic state fanatics
but
during the night really really heavy
bombardment we heard the jets
air strikes artillery uh
going in to those is positions uh
there's a hill
overlooking the encampment as well
machine gun fire
raking the islamic state how long of
course this lasts
when daesh will be finished as a
territorial entity
we simply don't know it may be that it
ends today it may be
tomorrow it may be much longer we don't
of course know how many is fighters
are still inside but what they are
controlling now
it really is a small scrap of land it
can't
be long you would think with all of the
the firepower raining down on them that
they can hold out for much longer